probably welcome to Hannity on this busy
Monday news night this is a Fox News
Alert it is now official credible
bribery allegations against your
President Joe Biden have taken on a
whole new meaning as of today and
tonight the evidence frankly is
overwhelming Joe and Hunter Biden were
in business together and apparently Joe
was the centerpiece of his family's get
rich quick scheme now Hunter admitted
last week he was a hardcore addict this
is an important part of the timeline
between 2003 and 2019 including of
course his crack cocaine addiction but
he was not making millions from his
expertise when it comes to hard drugs
hookers prostitutes you name it instead
he was allegedly selling access to what
is known as the brand that brand of
course would be his father Joe Biden his
position the vice president of this
country new bomb show closed door
testimony today from Hunter Biden's
longtime business partner and friend
Devin Archer was devastating for the
Biden family Syndicate and the Democrats
that support them in a moment we're
going to take you inside of that hearing
with house oversight committee chairman
James Comer and house Judiciary
Committee chairman Jim Jordan but let's
begin with what we know from Archer's
testimony from earlier today first Joe
Biden's repeated promise that he never
had anything to do with his son's
business deals that was an outright lie
both as a candidate and as a President
Joe Biden also repeatedly lied about I
never talked to my son Hunter my brother
or anyone else for that matter about any
foreign business deals a huge lie and
according to Archer we learned today
that Biden took part in over 20 phone
calls with Hunters foreign business
associates now this allegedly includes
Hunter's Ukrainian Partners at the
Ukrainian oil giant barisma Holdings and
more importantly at a critical moment
when the entire Ukrainian oil Giants
future was hanging in the balance it was
in Jeopardy Archer claims that Barista
paid Hunter Millions to sit on that
board so that his father the big guy
would Shield the company from
investigations now go back remember the
1023 form of course by a credible Source
credible as defined by the FBI because
they paid this FBI informant hundreds of
thousands of dollars but anyway they
quoted the barisma CEO on that 1023 form
as saying he thought Hunter was stupid
he thought his dog was smarter than
Hunter Biden how he didn't want to pay
the bidens but he forked over 5 million
for each of them and how it would take
people 10 years for anybody to figure
out how those payments were made then
right on cue let's go back to 2015
barisma Executives allegedly at the time
putting constant pressure on Hunter
Biden to Lobby his vice president father
about a certain Ukrainian prosecutor by
the name of Victor shulkin who is a
investigating barisma and Hunter for
corruption Hunter and his parisma bosses
even called Washington D.C together
according to Archer this is from Dubai
and wouldn't you know it short time
later Joe Biden went to Ukraine short
time after that Joe leveraged one
billion U.S taxpayer dollars to force
that very same prosecutor out of office
they gave him six hours to do it and Son
of a bee they fired him and guess who
continue to get paid after the firing
his son Hunter Biden who went on Good
Morning America and admitted he had no
experience in oil energy gas or even
Ukraine but it's not just barisma and
it's not just Ukraine Archer testified
that Joe Biden also participated in
Hunter's sketchy business transactions
in communist China and Russia including
conversations with high-profile Chinese
businessmen remember the WhatsApp
message that was a very important moment
or two I am sitting here with my father
well after that little exchange well
within a week five million dollars was
transferred to the bidens also the
former first lady of Moscow a Woman by
the name of Elena batarina and then in
2014 then Vice President Biden even
attended a business dinner with this
Russian oligarch who by the way was
mysteriously omitted how strange the
former first lady of Moscow one of the
richest people in in Russia yeah omitted
from the Biden administration's
sanctions against Russian oligarchs but
according to the latest Democratic
talking points parroted by the media mob
this was just a mere coincidence because
Hunter was merely just selling an
illusion of access to his father these
were mere pleasantries when his daddy
called in really take a look a source
familiar with the matter tells me that
you know Archer told the committee that
Hunter Biden was selling the illusion
illusion in quotes of access to his
father you know his father not directly
in advocating President Joe Biden in any
of the foreign dealings but rather
saying that Hunter Biden was trying to
essentially trick business partners into
thinking he could provide access direct
access to his father
oh that's right they now want you to
believe that the crack addict Hunter
Biden was tricking his very smart
sophisticated Cutthroat Farm business
partners I mean they must be really dumb
into forking over in each country
millions and millions of dollars in cash
or rather he was just performing an
illusion the White House says this was
oh much you do about nothing accusing
Republicans of wasting time and
resources but if the last name were
Trump what do you think they'd be
talking about every second every minute
every hour of every day every week every
month for the next three years after the
hearing a very nervous looking
Democratic Congressman nothing but an
apologist for all things Biden Dan
Goldman the congressman admitting Joe
frequently spoke to his son's business
partners but according to Goldman they
only talk pretty much about like the
weather and remember Joe Biden said
repeatedly he never one time talked to
his son his brother or anybody for that
matter about their foreign business
dealings take a look
you're saying that the speakerphone
conversations they don't seem concerning
to you because there is no specifics
about business and it just seemed like
it was clear that it was clear that it
was part of the daily conversations that
Hunter Biden had with his father
um and it was and and sound is like most
of the time uh
now President Biden didn't even know who
the people he was at dinner he was just
asked to say hello uh and he would you
know talk about the what he described it
several times they asked over and over
and over he described what the weather
was how uh how what's going on on your
end clearly he talked whether it's about
the weather or whatever but he said
specifically that he's never talked to
them doesn't this contradict me I don't
know what his comment is and if we're
gonna well I don't I don't think that's
what he said he never said that he has
never spoken to anyone he said that he
had nothing to do with Hunter Biden's
business dealings if he says hello to
someone that he sees his son with was he
supposed to say hi son oh no I'm not
going to say hello to the other people
at the table or the other people on the
phone it's kind of a Preposterous
premise to think that a father should
not say hello to people that the Sun or
at dinner with
20 plus business meetings Farm business
partners millions of dollars on the line
uh the CEO of Barista right there in the
room Joe Biden on speaker how's the
weather in Ukraine now of course we all
remember the big lie again and again as
a candidate and as President Joe Biden
said he never had anything to do with
his son's business deals never spoke to
him about these business deals not one
time now here's a question why would Joe
Biden lie so passionately he's only
talking about the weather and if Hunter
was conducting legitimate business well
I'd like to know what services he was
rendering exactly what value did he add
to barisma what value did he add to the
former first lady of Moscow the oligarch
what value did he add to the cefc uh
Executives that he was dealing with
China's Big Oil Company state-run Oil
Company it's pretty obvious everything
centered around pops and by the way over
the weekend on Saturday his father's doj
they sent a nice letter demanding that
Devin Archer soon report to prison for
an unrelated conviction he has a year he
has to serve some believe a blatant
intimidation tactic arches attorneys in
the doj now claim oh no the the letter
was totally unrelated just just bad
timing another strange coincidence and
according to the doj they always act
with the upright honor and integrity a
higher honor we've heard that before
well except for the truly unbelievable
sweetheart deal with Hunter that fell
apart after a federal judge started
asking simple questions like um okay why
are you agreeing not to charge Hunter on
any other issue moving forward oh that
was the real deal anyway questions uh we
have a lot tonight Jim Jordan has
announced a new joint house
investigation by the way into that deal
but make no mistake this is now a
two-part Scandal it involves serious
bribery allegations against the sitting
president of the United States and a
cover-up by his Department of Justice
that has been politicized and weaponized
that same doj that throws the book at
his chief political rival that guy's
name is Donald Trump and meanwhile
remember Hunter Biden's pricey portraits
of a crackhead well we have breaking
news at this hour John Solomon's
editor-in-chief just thenews.com some of
those masterpieces paint by numbers
might have gone all the way to China hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else